rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message be fearless over to you Satguru
not a single day passes for me right
without witnessing tears of joy and love
around me every day somebody will be
shedding tears of love and joy I don't
think there's a better way to live in
this world and all of us should strive
to create our own circles of joyfulness
and pleasantness around us because if
you are not joyful by your own nature if
you are always going around with the
fear of suffering as long as fear of
suffering is there within you you will
never walk your life with full stride it
will always be half a step most human
beings have crippled themselves simply
because of fear of suffering what will
happen to me is always the question
whatever happens this is how I will be
if this assurance comes to you only now
you will want to scale the peaks of life
and see what about it if it happens
makes no difference to you if it doesn't
happen makes no difference to you that's
when you would like to really explore
every dimension of life so first and
foremost thing is this that your way of
being is not determined by what's around
you if you bring this one aspect to you
there is no fear of suffering once there
is no fear of suffering you will
traverse the breadth and length of this
life without hesitation so I really love
watching Sadhguru and hearing his wisdom
and advice and I think of all the people
that I profile in this channel there's
maybe nobody else that I disagree with
as much as well or I conflict with I
love the message and I disagree
at the same time which means that I need
to keep profiling him when I need to
keep learning the messages my take on
this is I don't think you can be
fearless I agree with the message that
fear should not be the thing that's
holding you back from doing the thing
that you want to go off and do fear of
suffering or fear of anything should not
hold you back from pursuing your dreams
and going after your goals but I don't
know how to get to the point of being
completely fearless maybe if you get to
to yogi level maybe that's just a
limiting belief for myself I've never
met anybody who's completely fearless I
think the important thing that was that
when you feel the fear then you have to
go out and still do the thing anyway
I look at filming here as an example
I've told this story couple times
filming here with people walking by
would make me nervous when we first
started and it's funny how we get some
comments that this is a green screen is
that a green screen with them all behind
you like this is not a green screen this
is a real mall this is my Turner that
sells a studio and those are real people
walking behind me and so when I started
doing it I felt nervous that people were
watching and some people look in while
I'm filming in feeling that fear and
knowing where I want to go knowing the
kind of channel that I want to build and
know the impact that I want to have
means I need to be able to overcome that
fear and I found that all the greatest
things that I've ever accomplished in my
life and the and the big feelings of joy
and happiness and excitement have come
by busting through a fear that I had and
so getting used to when I feel that not
on my stomach of feeling afraid to do
something that I push through it because
I know something great is on the other
side of that wall of fear and so I don't
know that you can become fearless I
don't have the answer people to do it
may be said good who does what I agree
with him in that whatever that fear is
that you have it should not hold you
back from living the life that you want
to live so the question of the day today
is I'm curious can you be fearless
is it possible and if so do you have a
resource to share with me I would love
to hear from you please leave it down in
the comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to the Priyanka Chopra
fan club thank you so much you're
picking up a copy of my new book the top
ten rose to success with Priyanka on the
cover right there she made it she has
such great advice and so I'm glad that
you picked up the book in our love
as well thank you so much for your
support and tweeting out the picture as
well so thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
the see again tomorrow morning for
another shot event spresso
right after the HBO show aired I
produced two feature films that were
that were a big hit they premiered at
like Cannes Film Festival and Sundance
and I like got an award that Natalie
Portman gave me on TV that my dad
watched and it was like a big big deal
and I just like I remember having this
moment where I realized that like I was
so deep into this thing that wasn't
really it didn't feel right to me and
it's different trying to trying to find
opportunities when you are in a place of
success when you're in a place of
comfort like I was no longer starving I
wasn't hungry anymore I had some
recognition but something didn't feel
right and that was when I took this big
pivot and that pivot was to like you
know what it's not the politics it's not
the Natalie Portman giving me the award
about the schmoozing then I love I love
telling stories telling stories is my
passion and that was when I decided to
sort of walk away from TV even walk away
from movies and I just wanted to make
youtube videos and I remember like my
big Hollywood agent when I sort of told
that to him he was like in case you know
you know this is four years ago YouTube
five years you know YouTube was nothing
it was something that was silly it was
like a really great place to go and
watch cats play the piano and I wanted
to like parlay my career as a very
successful filmmaker into into that and
I can't tell you the opportunities that
were birthed from that it's given me
what I have today that's opportunity
those are opportunities those are
opportunities that in the moment I
couldn't have told you were
opportunities I didn't know what they
were there was something that just felt
right there was something that looked
right I did my best calculations I took
my best guess it wasn't reckless I never
operate recklessly and this is an
important differentiation between
recklessness fearlessness I always do my
best to operate without fear don't not
do something don't skip something
because I'm afraid to do it but make
sure it's a smart decision and then part
two of that is is is obligation I feel
obliged to embrace opportunities like
that
I thought obliged to quit my job I felt
obliged to walk away from HBO and the
was because there was something in me
there's a truth that I wanted and the
obligation was to embrace that we've got
some difficult days ahead but it really
doesn't matter with me now because I've
been to the mountaintop like anybody I
would like to live a long life longevity
has its place but I'm not concerned
about that now I just want to do God's
will and he's allowed me to go up to the
mountain and I've seen the promised land
to the promised man
but along with being the Chilean cookie
at a very young age came advice from my
parents which I think a lot of our
parents in this room have probably given
us you were going to have to be bigger
if I better just to be considered people
what it does to the self-esteem of a
small child is to say that you are
always going to not be good enough so at
school I try to do this to my left so I
have a big lips one day - like how to
make sure that I always got those you're
so articulated compliments which my way
if you ever say that's what adult it's
actually not
I wanted to make sure my hair was so
straight I used to leave relaxers on my
hair so long I would get me shoes
because I wanted to fit in I wanted to
be good enough I didn't want to get joke
I didn't want to be a loser
anytime some guys not return my love it
was because I'm not good enough because
I'm a joke a loser when I got raped at
19 I have less of the job it wasn't just
some awful coincidence some terrible
freak accident it wasn't an unspeakable
crime it was because if I was a joke in
a loser and this is what happens when I
got divorced my children lose ofcourse
show is cancelled of course
and on that day in August I started
doing the work they were like you've
gotta replace that and voice in your
head that's telling you you're a joke
and so you've gotta stop being crippled
by a fear of possible humiliation other
voice that pops up in your head that
says don't raise your hand you're not
gonna answer the question right don't
put that on you're too big don't wear
your hair like that it's so ugly nothing
in my closet works I'm so dumb I can't
do it no one's gonna love me why is my
painting need for place that and then
sounded so cliche is so easy and that
day I decided to stop telling myself I
was a junkie loser but that I was still
and fly if you have to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you up or so it would be kind of
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details